one of the
amazing things you've done for the world
is
to some degree open sourcing the tooling
that you use to make your videos
with madam this python
library now it's quickly evolving
because i think you're inventing new
things every time you make a video
in fact i wanted um i've been working on
playing around with something i wanted
to do like an ode to three blue one
brown like i love playing hendrix
i wanted to do like a cover you know of
a concept i wanted to visualize and
and use madam and i saw that you had
like a little piece of code on like
mobius strip
and i tried to do some cool things with
spinning a mobius strip
like continue um twisting it i guess is
the term
uh and it was easier to uh
it was tough so i haven't figured out
yet well so i guess the question i want
to ask
is so many people love it uh that you've
put that out there they want to uh do
the same things they do with hendrix
they want to cover it they want to
explain an idea using the tool
including russ how would you recommend
they try to i'm very sorry they try to
go
they try to go by uh about it
well so and what kind of choices should
they choose
to be most effective oh that i can
answer so
i always feel guilty if this comes up
because um i think of it like this
scrappy tool
that's like a math teacher who put
together some code people asked what it
was so they made it open source
and they kept scrapping it together and
there's a lot like a lot of things about
it that make it harder to work with than
it needs to be
that are a function of like me not being
a software engineer
i i've put some work this year trying to
like make it
better and more flexible um that is
still just kind of like
a work in process um one thing i would
love to
do is just get my act together about
properly integrating with what like the
community wants to work with
and like what stuff i work on and making
that
um not like deviate uh and just like
actually fostering that community in a
way that i've
i've been like shamefully neglectful of
so i'm just always guilty if it comes up
so let's put that guilt aside just okay
then like
i'll pretend like it isn't terrible for
someone like russ um
i think step one is like make sure that
what you're animating should be done so
programmatically because a lot of things
maybe shouldn't um like if you're just
making a quick graph of something
if it's a graphical intuition that maybe
has a little motion to it
use desmos use grapher use geogebra use
mathematica
certain things that are like really
oriented around ground georgia is kind
of cool
it's amazing you can get very very far
with it um and in a lot of ways like
it would make more sense for some stuff
that i do to just do in geogebra
but i kind of have the cycle of liking
to try to improve mana by doing videos
and such so
do as i say not as i do the original
like thought i had in making manum was
that there's so many different ways of
representing functions other than graphs
in particular things like
transformations like use movement over
time to communicate relationships
between inputs and outputs
instead of like x direction and y
direction
or like vector fields or things like
that so i wanted something that was
flexible enough that you didn't feel
constrained into a graphical environment
um
by graphical i mean like graphs with uh
like x coordinate y coordinate kind of
stuff
but also make sure that um you're
taking advantage of the fact that it's
programmatic you have loops you have
conditionals you have abstraction
if any of those are like well fit for
what you want to teach to
you know have a scene type that you
tweak a little bit based on parameters
or to have conditionals so that things
can go one way or another or loops so
that you can create these
things of like arbitrarily increasing
complexity that's the stuff that's like
meant to be animated programmatically
if it's just like writing some text on
the screen or shifting around objects or
something like that
um things like that you should probably
just use keynote
right um you'll be a lot simpler so uh
try to find a workflow that distills
down
that which should be programmatic into
manum and that which doesn't need to be
into like other domains again do as i
say not as i
do
you